apple finally released a magsafe
wireless charging pack
but unfortunately you should not buy one
and even though
i ordered two of them right away after
some new
findings and specifications that are not
immediately noticeable
i am fairly certain that i will end up
returning both of them
and instead using some of these that i
have
for a number of reasons now like always
i have links down below
if you guys want to pick one of these up
but i would recommend just waiting a
little bit till i get that and i'll give
you guys
all the info that you need just like i
showed off
in my ultimate wireless charging pack
comparison video which you guys
really enjoyed but in that video where
there were some
really good comments that made a lot of
sense for example
ellie said that sounds like none of
these are actually magsafe compatible
they are just chargers with magnets and
that is completely true they're regular
wireless chargers
with the alignment magnets which make
them more convenient
and with that we have a comment about
waiting for the official one
because of faster charging speeds and
that is the number one reason why i'm
excited for these and of course somebody
also mentioned waiting for reverse
wireless charging to be
unlocked and we'll talk about that in
just a bit
now here on the main page we have the
100 price tag
which is actually a little bit lower
than i expected i thought it's gonna be
129
but other than that in some of these
pictures that show off the only option
being available
being white and some rubbery silicone
material on the back for good grip which
is awesome
we don't have that much info the look is
very clean very simplistic there is no
power button which is actually a really
good
thing and it also doesn't show off what
port
it uses but scrolling down we get a
little bit more info
showing that you do need a lightning
port to charge this
and unlike most battery packs it does
not come with the cable in the box
of course you have to buy that
separately or use one that you already
have
now there are a couple of really great
benefits with this one compared to other
options
and that is that you'll actually get a
notification on your phone as far as the
charge capacity
so that is very convenient and this
battery pack
will allow reverse wireless charging
with your iphone
12s and that is a feature that people
waiting for for a while
but unfortunately it is only to charge
the battery pack
itself now another cool feature that you
get which you get with most of these
is that you can use it as a wireless
charging base station so you can plug it
in at your desk
set your phone on top and when you're
ready to go you just pick it up
you don't need a dedicated wireless
charger so it can pass through
that is really cool and it'll wait till
your phone's charged until it charges
the internal battery
but with that you can actually plug in
your phone
and then it'll charge your phone and
once it's done it will reverse
wirelessly charge the battery pack as
well
now personally that is not that exciting
to me because if i'm on a fast charge
i'll plug in my phone
and the only time i'm going to leave it
plugged in that long to charge my phone
and then the battery pack is at night
in that case i might as well just plug
the pack in itself what i really want
reverse wireless charging for
is for air pods and an apple watch would
be amazing
to be able to charge from your iphone
other than that info
there is very little details about the
charging speed how much charge you will
actually get
or what the capacity is which apple did
actually state with their previous
smart battery case it will tell you how
much of the charge your phone will get
from it
and that is a little bit worrisome but
if we go ahead and look into
apple's dedicated page that has extra
info we get a few really important
points
and we can also find a page which helps
you find the serial number
but there zoomed in we actually see the
capacity which is a thousand four
hundred and sixty milliamp
hours that is super low but doesn't tell
the whole story
so this one right here that i have is
4200 this one's 5 000 so 14
60 is low but the voltage is actually
double what you typically have inside
your phone or inside
of these battery packs that you can buy
that means if we do the math the actual
milliamp
hours is about 29.20 so that is much
better
and that is slightly higher than an
iphone 12 or 12 pro
lower than the pro max but it is still
not
as good as these which have larger
batteries
and of course that 10.8 watt hour
battery rating
is just the battery itself that doesn't
account for inefficiencies
when you're pulling energy from a
battery or inefficiencies
when you're on top of that wirelessly
charging
most battery banks that use a cable to
charge your phone they have
80 to 90 efficiency 90 is
very very good the best of the best and
then on top of that you have loss from
wireless charging
so most of these mag saves when i tested
it
their actual efficiency was about 45
to 48 of the rated one so this one
from a 5 000 milliamp rating actually
gave you about 2 400
that you can get into your phone now i
do think that apples will be better than
45
efficiency with their better batteries
higher voltage and the magsafe
but doing some research most people say
that 70 is probably
the high end and quinn from snazzy labs
did some math as well and that is being
optimistic so if we do the math that
would mean that your iphone 12 will get
roughly
a 70 total charge from the power bank
and looking at these other options that
i reviewed
this one right here which is actually
the cheapest one gives you 68
percent so even with the extra
efficiency
you're not going to get a full charge
and on an iphone 12 pro max
that might be closer to about a 50
charge
only so that is definitely a bummer
but that wasn't the end of the world i
didn't buy it for
how much capacity it had i bought it
because i want fast wireless charging
most of these third-party options will
either give your iphone 7.5 watts
or 5 watts even though they'll say 15 or
20 that's only for android phones and
who would buy this for an android phone
and then that is the rated capacity
whereas i
tested what actually goes into your
phone after loss
and some of these will do seven on the
better end some will do six that are
less efficient
and then this one's rated five actually
gave you 3.5
where magsafe is more efficient it can
actually give you close to that
15 watts which is fantastic but this is
where
the story really turns for the worst if
we dig
into apple's support page it says that
yes you can get that really fast 15 watt
max save charging
but only if you're plugging a 20 watt or
higher cable
into it and using it as a wireless
charger
if you unplug it when you're on the go
you will only get
5 watts of rated wireless charging
so that comment that said they're
waiting for
uh apple's official one for fast
charging that's exactly what we were
waiting for
unfortunately that is just not the case
and even if apple can reach that five
watts of actual
wireless charging instead of 3.5 that is
still slower than the seven that you can
get
with this hyper power and we haven't
even talked about prices
just yet now what does that mean in the
real world
well in my actual ultimate comparison we
see
that 3.5 watts of real charging only
gets you 13
after 30 minutes and then the faster
7.5 that gives you seven into the phone
which is gonna be better than apples
only gives you 23 charge compared to
actual magsafe the way it should work
which will give you
30 charge in 30 minutes and even
more than that as far as how fast it
charges under
30 minutes and then after an hour max
safe would give you 55
but you will actually get somewhere
between
28 to 35 charge
in one hour so that is
really really slow so not only will you
get a low capacity from that battery
the charging speed will be much slower
but it actually gets
worse in one more way apple decided to
stick with lightning instead of going
with usb type-c
like with most of these third-party
options and that means that you cannot
get power out
any other way than wirelessly charging
which is much slower
much less efficient and you have less
capacity
with these options right here you can
plug a cable in if you have one and in
that case
you will get more capacity so this one
right here instead of charging 68
with an iphone 12 you will get 100
charge and it'll also be about three
times
faster to charge compared to wireless
charging so in those scenarios
you can use it as a standard fast
wireless charging
bank or just regular power bank unless
you need the convenience of not having a
cable
and with that you can plug in an apple
watch charger
any other you know lightning cable for
air pods an
android phone or anything else your
bluetooth speaker and you can get more
power whereas with apple's option
you can't do that it's only for wireless
charging the slow and less efficient
way and then comes in the price point
apple's cost a hundred bucks whereas
this guy right here i bought for
28 so this has similar capacity
and similar charging speed more
flexibility
and it is about you know a third of the
price less than a third of the price
and this one right here that has more
capacity this will charge 85 percent
it'll charge faster it comes in at 40
and it also has a usbc
output as well so let me know your
thoughts
of course we're going to get these in
i'm going to be putting to the test
hopefully they do better than what
they're advertised
but this info is from apple themselves
it's not from
anybody else so once we test it i'll do
my final review you guys click that
subscribe button above
if you guys want to see that but for now
if you need to buy something i'll have
links down in the video description to
what i recommend
and check out the ultimate wireless
charging video right over there
that's been maxed and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]